i've done the seven-day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations alhamdulillah i was worried
that it was an overrated product you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses no credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah so i came across a video on
instagram of a brother who's on the
train and he's reading the quran and as
he's reading somebody who may have jin
inside him has started reacting to it
i'm gonna do it on public transport
where i'm sitting okay i was here you do
not even have the decency to ask me if
you can do it i don't need your
permission yeah you need your my
permission to invite my privacy in my
space you're over there i'm over here
yeah but i like your noise that you make
okay travel if you have an issue i do
have an issue a lot of people have an
issue with movies
sitting here doing their morning prayers
i don't care no
what you are doing is invading other
people's face no i'm not yes you are no
one's having a problem yes you are all
right nobody wants to tell you to stop
because they are too careful because oh
my god touch a muslim let me do
something this is a christian country
you behave in our manners the way that
we do guys as you can see on the video
um i've been on trains you know i
actually love going on trains i prefer
the trains over cars any days that's why
i leave my car with my wife and
sometimes you know even if i am reading
the quran um i know the person opposite
me cannot hear me because it gets quite
loud now the underground is very loud
it's impossible for someone to make any
excuses that they are disturbed by the
other person because everybody's
disturbed by the loud noise now this
specific one i think it's over grant if
i'm not mistaken but even on the
overground it is still noisy when the
train is going other trains are coming
so i very highly doubt that this person
is going to be affected by somebody um
reading out loud and i very highly doubt
that the muslim brother was reciting
he wasn't doing that he was reading it
in a small manner maybe he might be
hearing some stuff like you know it
might sound like sound that someone's
mumbling but again i don't think it's
the quran that disturbed this individual
like what he um he was being disturbed
by the noise i genuinely think it's that
this person probably has a gin inside
you know and the quran is a shifa for
that you know he's probably got some
fugitives maybe he's got a whole family
maybe he's got
uh his whole entire family in his head
maybe i don't know for him to react in
that manner and not only that it's
either that or it's the fact that
islamophobia people like douglas murray
tommy robinson jordan peterson uh not
just excuse me
um
paul golding jada franzen um and other
individuals who propagate lies about
islam and fear-monger individuals that's
the reason why i made a clear-cut
challenge to douglas murray on this
specific topic you know is islam a
threat to the west you know and i will
debate any day any time because this
specific topic i know he has nowhere to
go you know we would love to see what is
real terrorism when we see what the
western world has been doing to so many
countries atrocities in the millions we
would like to see who is really a threat
to who i would like to debate that but
they don't and they don't understand
that people like
individuals who carried out the attacks
on finsbury park and also the attacks in
christchurch in new zealand where they
massacred 52 people were most likely
watched their videos now they don't in
directly ask for violence to happen but
indirectly like hitler if you
systematically dehumanize a individual
or a group of people why do you get
surprised when people are ready to take
people's lives this man is a byproduct
of that you can see that he's at the
early stages of being radicalized the
next thing might be he might one day
wake up and say you know what enough is
enough the way he was talking and saying
this is a christian country and you need
to he's got some kind of insecurities
what is it that we are um asking you
guys to do what are we saying are we
saying let's turn the entire uh uk into
a
an islamic land etc what is it that
we're asking you we want freedom to pray
we practice our religion and we do not
want hate towards us which ends up
causing our hijabi sisters getting the
hijabs pulled off or our muslim brothers
and sisters who are going about their
daily life to be attacked stabbed run
over or shot
that is what we're asking nobody's
asking for for anything special or
special rights you know if there's
anyone that's asking for special rights
it's israel yes you cannot criticize
them you cannot even boycott them you
cannot even boycott them and douglas
murray this absolute uh scum is an
absolute supporter of baby killers 66
plus children murdered massacred in
israel and he is there telling me that
the two thousand pounds that i
challenged him that i would give him for
me to donate it to a terrorist
organization like the idf you can see
clearly that that is there to avoid it
and you can see just in a nutshell bomb
system i don't want to long that too
much but this brother is doing this
thing and these individuals are
islamophobes who want nothing but their
issue is
with the quran
this is their issue we know this from
the quran from day one allah tells us
that we saw what they were doing with
the believers they persecuted them for
no reason except they say
that is from the get-go from this day
their problem with us is
they do not like the fact that the
treasures are being closed nobody's
going to the churches and it's been
turned into mosques blame yourself don't
say this a christian country you have
turned this in to a country that is not
christian so don't blame know about
yourself if we are firm with our faith
and we are practicing it well that shame
on you yes we believe in the oneness of
god and we are here to propagate it to
the masses and to the people and there
are many people who have come to islam
so in a nutshell i wanted to share that
with you guys i don't want to hold this
too much longer but biggest like that
will never stop us from reciting the
quran without disturbing individuals
anyone else and like i said before i
highly doubt he was disturbed he is
disturbed because he's an insecure
little boy you know what lucky job says
come here let me slap you intellectually
of course till next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh